ei
foi um dia
o sabão em barra 1 c e daí sul e dia o
'samba round e só aí tea é aqui que é
aqui e agora aqui agora então é suposto
falar alguma coisa
a preocupação falar só 15 minutos
então vai lá sustentabilidade
telepresença brasil rio de janeiro
metrópole agravante dessa palestra não é
recomendável para casos de dengue
caso persistam sintomas procure um
médico paciente 15 minutos
no entanto à noite 15 minutos
meu deus vou voltar pro barros e daí
sair ea site chinês três balcões ouro
restauração que tem 300 anos do ritual
de purificação do taoísmo diz que os
três tesouros do universo através da
paixão paixão comum que tem com agentes
da força de proteção
na verdade a gente recebe a proteção dos
36 anos do universo por essa compaixão
paixão em comum e quais são os três
seções universo quais são vazio
consciência ea ação vazio consciência
ação se lembra uma agência de propaganda
brasil consciência à ação de criação do
universo vazio consciência ação e ansa
aníbal tal alta em termos religiosos
criança o princípio gerador dos inícios
animal o tesouro da consciência tal alta
o caminho ea virtude da prática ou o
drama bicho o shiva ou pai espírito
santo e filho são a trindade sagrada é
esse vazio inicial que um grupo de
pessoas houve por chamar de tal tal é
apenas um nome
a única religião que nunca teve guerras
atrás dela porque não tem nada por trás
não tem o país não tem uma meta total e
apenas um nome que se dá à a esse vazio
ali atrás estatal danielle tal
e aqui está escrito no comecinho talca
tal fechamnto almir encaminho fez em mim
o tal que pode ser tal usado não é o tal
verdadeiro o nome que pode ser nomeado
não é o nome que dure tal é apenas um
nome que eu tava tem a ver com ted a
gente começar pela letra t que teria que
pode trazer pra gente aqui vamos dar um
outro próximo tal dizem os mestres
sempre bom falar disso os mestres a
ficar forte né
dizem os mestres que tudo que existe no
universo é sustentado por alguma coisa e
tudo que existe no universo envolvido
por alguma coisa a isso que sustenta
tudo que existe
chama-se terra essa é nossa terra nas
usinas de longe não tão mas o olhar de
perto mas a lua é uma terra marte é uma
terra o sol é uma terra atividade vital
no sol é vital para nós inclusive mas
essa é a nossa terra e tudo que envolve
tudo que existe no universo chama-se céu
esse é o nosso céu azul anil só porque
nós temos uma atmosfera porque o céu é
preto negro escuro você já viu da lua
sócio da lua
nós somos brindados com o céu de anil e
um planeta da aneel
então tudo que existe no universo é
sustentado por uma terra tudo que existe
no universo envolvido por um céu
nós dizemos e aquilo que sustenta terra
envolve o céu
nós chamamos de tal uma nova aproximação
de tal o que isso tem a ver com esse
momento tem a ver com esse momento
a pergunta que eu faço pra vocês qual é
a relação real de vocês com o planeta
falou de projetos
o dia inteiro de projetos maravilhosos o
que relação isso tem a ver com o planeta
não é esse nosso planeta azul zinho é
vocês saberiam dizer sentados aqui sem
pedir para alguém entrou que alguém meça
qual é a parte do planeta que está mais
perto de vocês agora vocês saberiam
dizer não vou dizer não é só sobre a
forma você saberia me dizer quantos
metros tem né tem metrô tem um monte de
coisa embaixo onde começa o planeta que
parte de vocês o que parte do planeta
está mais perto de vocês
você saberia me dizer que parte do céu
normalmente o mais perto aquele que a
gente tem maior responsabilidade em cima
do manto velhinho não posso usar muito
que não existe uma que está mais perto
que eu tenho mais responsabilidade
o que eu tenho de mais responsabilidade
nesse planeta
se eu disser que eu tenho de mais
responsabilidade no planeta que eu vou
devolver quando saí do planeta está
dando uma dica ou se eu disser o que
você ganha quando você nasceu em uma
fazenda da família em uma fazenda do
norte perdeu a fazer antes disso é um
tapinha na bunda do médico
antes disso antes disso há nenhum corpo
a corpo
só o corpo são um corpo se você está
falando você mussungue não ganha uma
respiração
então ao chegar no planeta eu ganho um
corpo uma respiração eu ganho por aqui
está tendo essa experiência maravilhosa
me assusta quando as pessoas dizem que
jogo quando tomam água
os quatro primeiros prazeres deveriam
ser humano sentir se vivo primeiro
prazer
segundo cíntia energia terceiro sentir o
prazer da respiração eo quarto prazer da
água
depois queria sexo sangue essas coisas
todas
o então é isso esse corpo é só para ter
o prazer não não a gente tem que fazer
mais qualidade sem ter que fazer umas
coisas não esse corpo e sua
responsabilidade pessoal
responsabilidade não faça do seu corpo
uma arma não faça do seu corpo uma arma
então a sua responsabilidade principal é
sobre seu corpo só sobre seu corpo sob
sua respiração
vocês já perceberam que estão vivos
porque tem um corpo e tem uma respiração
senti um pouquinho adiante né
o escritor ocidental antigo testamento
deus operou o barro quando você está
respirando está respirando deus quando
você está andando você está levando com
você é um pedaço da terra que saiu do
ventre de sua mãe que está aqui que você
tem que devolver espera um pouquinho já
morto
você tem que devolver então meus amigos
a parte do planeta terra mais perto de
vocês é o seu corpo
oras bolas seu corpo à parte do céu que
está mais perto de você é a sua rede e
da ação que outra maneira de ver isso
a minha responsabilidade é o que o
aparelho do metrô que carla não o erro
que está vazando isso é do prefeito
o hall de entrada do edifício do síndico
não é meu hobby mandar a dona maricota
toma conta das plantinhas meu
apartamento à é responsável
é de minha eu tenho detergente
biodegradável xampu biodegradável toalha
degradável microondas biodegradáveis
lançaram serviram cozinha depois se joga
fora da terra os passarinhos com ele
smartphones biodegradável televisão de
70 polegadas vida agradável roupa
biodegradável e eu sou biodegradável
essa é uma outra maneira de ver que o
meu corpo é a minha principal
responsabilidade e que isso faz parte do
planeta e o que o tal e o tal cantal
fechando tal tem a ver com isso
tv que foi escrito há 3.500 anos atrás
um livro chamado downgrading chama the
tao te king foi escrito por cláusula que
a gente chama de lao tsé que diz o
seguinte aqui vocês vão ver que estou
falando tem alguma coisa a ver com o que
acontece aqui o que é bem plantado
ninguém arranca o que é bem engraçado
ninguém tira ano estão plantando idéias
que vale a pena ser divulgadas
espalhadas as idéias velhinhas essas
idéias que estou trazendo tem 7.500 anos
acaba caindo s10 tem 7.500 anos então
técnico no capítulo 54 disso o que é bem
plantado ninguém que arranca o que é bem
abraçado ninguém tira e só assim as
gerações futuras e de agradecer
agradecer este tinha xixi
quero agradecer eternamente mas para
isso continua o técnico restauro seu
corpo e sua ação ser autêntica restauro
e depois da sua casa e sua ação será
grande
só são suas virtudes são virtudes são
praticamente a mesma palavra em chinês a
atenção sendo estúdio nem visto
dissensão restauro seu corpo e sua
virtude ser autêntica depois sua casa e
sou virtude será grande
depois a sua metrópole sobretudo será
crescente
depois do seu reino seu país e sobretudo
será farta
depois do planeta e sua virtude será a
vasta diferença de farta para a vasta
existe fartos alimentos no planeta mas
não estão vastos porque não estão sendo
distribuídos para todos porque dizes lá
o sul não tem como conhecer minha casa
sem o conhecer meu corpo não tem como eu
conhecer a cidade sem conhecer minha
casa não tem como eu conheci meu país
sem conhecer a cidade não tem como
conhecer o mundo sem conhecer o meu país
isso é propaganda de companhia de
turismo
isso é muito antigo
então era bom mas onde é que fica aquela
história de latinhas de cerveja de sacos
plásticos matando golfinhos
eu não devo fazer isso claro que sim
o que eu estou te king está falando
restaure o seu corpo e assim a sua ação
será autêntica civil indicaram
documentos 1
se você começa a consertar sua casa sem
estar ao seu corpo essa ação não é
autêntica não vai durar
leva o documento sem autocrítica
autenticação onde precisa vai durar até
quem está dizendo apenas se você quer
que só assis que sua ação seja têm a
autêntica que você quer que os projetos
vão pra frente restaure primeiro o seu
corpo depois o a sua casa e assim por
diante
o que mais nos traz essa filosofia de
sete mil e quinhentos anos segundo a
própria história em 5.500 anos
segundo a história da china 3.500 anos
porque dizem que foi o de samba que
começou mas não foi ela começou a
confundir a 7.500 anos no final da era
glacial que mais nos traz uma coisa bem
ecológica
as águas dos rios são sangue do planeta
a atmosfera é a respiração do planeta o
que seria o clima está criando maior
clima o clima ea mente do planeta eu
nunca vi ninguém que não fosse o tal
mesmo dizer isso
o clima é a mente do planeta é a psiquê
do planeta
olha que coisa interessante são se eu
estou aborrecido estão atrapalhando o
clima assim antes mesmo de você poluir
os rios você está poluindo o clima com a
sua mente
grande parte da confusão climática é
porque a mente do ser humano está
confusa grande parte e vira um ciclo
realimentado o clima doido ou descem 2
10 o homem um homem doido e desce o
crime assim vai vai vai
eu estava lendo esse texto tal de king e
morar em laranjeiras no prédio que
ficava do lado de lá janela ficava de
lado e eu estava lendo esse texto eo
juro para vocês
desceu uma nuvem a rua das laranjeiras
acho que é um disco voador de ser uma
nuvem 'redondinha' chovendo na rua de
laranjeiras e ou por trás de copacabana
o céu limpo grande parte do clima estar
doido tem a nossa mente do que trocar da
seicho-no-ie diz quando a mente dos
homens está calmo clima essa calma as
forças da natureza são um milhão de
vezes mais forte que a gente mas são
inocentes elas reagem às nossas ações
estão a começar a consertar o planeta
agora fica em uma posição confortável na
cadeira você estão cuidando do planeta
terra vamos lá
respire comigo apenas três vezes para
não virar uma hora de energético
apenas três vezes no mesmo ritmo para
começarem a consertar a atmosfera do
planeta vamos lá
de olhos fechados pense na coisa mais
alegre que aconteceu hoje sorriam
mecanicamente vocês estão ajudando o
clima do planeta
vamos lá pensem na coisa mais alegre que
lhes aconteceu assim que começa então
grandes empreendedores o que ajuda a
cabeça das pessoas e melhorar o clima
tai chi chuan khune e yoga psicanálise é
de um espaço na cidade para isso eu não
vi ninguém falar de espaço para fazer
este show população sim ainda estamos
carregando o planeta não planeta nos
leva se a gente entrar no ritmo do
planeta
não é essa a principal mensagem que eu
trago para vocês hoje e à eu quero
encerrar com uma coisa muito bonita
vou deixar agora no rosto humano
esquecendo que tirar o mandato então
isso acaba é a canção das flores
o ritual isso da purificação ele diz que
ninguém aí o earl que em barra mansa
roni a china mesmo que o espírito
desperto e tornando-se a flor celeste
que a sinceridade alcance o espaço
tornando se o aroma da verdade que flor
e aroma
preencha um momento no qual a lei a
pronunciada
os poderes são originados no qual todos
no universo recebe a sua lua que as suas
estrelas me liberte para alcançar o real
eo eterno sem sofrimento nem obstáculos
que eu possa reverenciar os mestres e
mestras da compaixão que eu possa
reverenciar os mestres e mestras dos
três tesouros
o que eu posso alcançar o grande
mistério dizendo que nunca vai cansar
alcançar o grande mistério
a preocupação dele pra que serve a vida
de onde vivemos só existe enquanto ele
está livre depois que a gente morre não
tem mais essa preocupação então quando
está viva no cabo na cabeça da gente
depois que ele morreu não precisa mais
que eu possa reverenciar os mestres da
compaixão os três sensores alcançar o
grande mistério essa próxima linha têm
medo de pedir mas eu vou te pedir faz
parte da oração que os céus acordem e se
transforma em retornando ao seu estado
original pode ser um desastre para a
gente os seus acordar e voltar ao seu
estado original
eu reverencio todos os reis são r rainha
celeste e todos os imortais e as
imortais
eu reverencio todos os homens e mulheres
autênticos
sagrados
eu reverencio todas as divindades todas
as religiões de todas as linhas que se
restaure o respeito especialmente
sentimento das famílias e países têm
alegria harmonia e atitude que famílias
e países tenham alegria harmonia
quietude que famílias e países tenham
harmonia alegria e quietude que os
corações sagrados torne-se mais firme
para que se comprove o maravilhoso
caminho da i liga minha mãe ficou doente
sim já comeu bem agasalhado sim
implicavam com isso custa perceber que
ela estava preocupada com o planeta
horas
agora se ligarem para você e falar em
quantas baleiro você já salvou do meu
filho
quantas usinas nucleares você pediu que
explodissem meu filho
e quantas vezes você salvou o mundo no
último mês
você pode olhar para baixo com certeza
você vai estar com uma cueca vermelha
por cima do manto do macacão azul e você
é o superman
muito obrigado sr